what was the distribution path with
weather girl weather girl we premiered
at slam dance we were one of their made
special screenings where you don't have
to be a first-time filmmakers so I was
able to do that it was great we went out
to a park city and we kind of used the
platform of Sundance to get attention
and brought out some of the talent like
you mentioned like you know there's a
great is a great cast in weather girl
Mark Harmon was supportive of the movie
Kaitlin Olson from Always Sunny in
Philadelphia and then patrick j adams
who is on suits now the USA show and
also he's one of the stars of six month
rule and Ryan Devlin anyways and Trish
Oh Kelly they're great cast and they're
all really supportive movie the movie
was so small and everybody did for two
hundred dollars a day and then they
followed through and supporting it all
the way to the end which i think is so
important when it comes to getting a
deal for your movie because it's not
just business it's it's the movie
business and people you know want to see
the stars they want to meet the cast and
you know if Mark Harmon is backing it it
must be good you know so anyways that
that happened we sold television rights
at at park city and then we wanted a
release because we didn't make it
specifically to be a television movie so
we did some maneuvering and basically
we're able to get a six-month window to
do with the at racal so we took some of
the money from the television deal and
we siphoned it into our own theatrical
release and did about ten cities and you
know it was great it was great then we
came out on TV and DVD and all that jazz
and it was awesome because the movie
didn't cost very much money and we made
back a huge bulk of it you know ninety
percent i think is well all made back in
the first couple of months which was
awesome for me because then i could turn
around and say here's my next movie and
my last movie made his money back so
what do you think and so there was a big
process of going out and raising money
for six month rule based on this same
model and yeah and it worked out
yeah so I'm consider myself very lucky
that any anytime anybody gives you money
to make a movie I mean you should just
thank your lucky stars is it the
greatest job in the world and it's such
a commitment of faith you know in a
filmmaker to be like here you go here's
a bunch of money make it into a piece of
art you know hons like okay well June
first what's happening in June first we
open in new york city at the village
east theater and then the next week we
open back in Los Angeles and then we're
rolling out to about six to ten other
cities after that and I'm just really
excited about it it's a yeah I've never
had a film premiere in New York so um
getting ready to go out there for that
that's gonna be awesome and then we're
on video on demand in August so it'll be
available nationwide you know anybody
with a cable box or Playstation
apparently now you can just watch
connect the future is awesome what are
you doing to prepare for this
distribution I'm trying not to have an
aneurysm naturally the biggest problem
i'm struggling with uh no it's you know
it's it's it's intense you know making
sure that everybody's got what they need
and you know the publicity and blah blah
doing lots of interviews like this to
try to tell people about it like we
don't have a huge budget for marketing
and whatnot so it literally is word of
mouth and you know follow us on Twitter
and Facebook please you know that cuz
act that's great like social media is
such a boon I think to two independent
film right now it's like the fact that
you can actually reach people without
having to go through a studio or a
television set or you know a radio
interview you can just reach out to them
and if they like what you're doing then
you know they'll support you and if not
they won't it's it's a really great time
to be out there and you know be
independent I think what are you doing
the social media or is your your
I have a whole firm that doesn't know
it's yeah it's just me uh you know I I
wish that there was some kind of office
that I had behind me that was like you
know mr. Weaver mr. Weaver nice report
from the Twittersphere yeah I had like
no I'm it's pretty much just me and you
know I've had a great support from the
cast you know everybody's so awesome you
know like i said patrick j adams who
starred in weather girl has this great
turn in this movie and his uh his show
suits is just taking off you know what's
going into its second season and he's
been incredibly supportive and natalie
morales is on the new aaron sorkin show
on HBO and she's been pushing it and
dave foley and john michael higgins and
everyone's just been so supportive and
reaching out to their fans and you know
telling him to come see the movie so I'm
really optimistic about how the
theatricals gonna go and I think I hope
people like the movie I think they will
well since you are team when we how many
hours there you're spending on all this
Oh a lot a lot um you know becomes an
obsession I mean you guys know as
filmmakers it's it's not just my job
it's you know I don't have a kid but I
would imagine that it's very similar to
you know what you would feel about your
child it's like there's not too much
work you can do it's like this is um the
the production office that I work at one
of the one of the girls that you know
helps me out with with stuff it was
giving me how the other day about me
freaking out and being obsessive of that
stuff and I'm like well it's not like
it's my life but it I mean you know what
I mean it's like two years of your life
you know everything everything has led
up to this all the people who have
entrusted me with money all the people
who have entrusted me with their image
you know and works for nothing work for
way under their quote weather behind the
camera in front of the camera all these
people made a bet on me and so there's
there's no too much you know there's no
end to if I don't do everything I
possibly
can to make this thing success then I
feel like I've let those people down so
I mean yeah Aidan noise you know people
my girlfriend's really bugged with me
right now the amount of time and energy
we spend on this but you know that's the
job and it's a really great job so I
can't complain about it too hard
you